Döner Kebab –
Grillfleisch vom Spieß im Fladenbrot
mit einer Salatmischung und Soße.
Ein beliebter Imbiss auf der ganzen Welt,
vor allem in Deutschland.
Also, es ist viel drin, sehr vielfältig
und sehr saftig!
Hat alles einfach!
Also, in der Türkei gibt es
das nur auf einem Teller,
aber nicht in dem Döner Kebab.
Das hat ein Berliner erfunden.
Fest steht: „Döner Kebab“ ist türkisch für „sich
drehendes Grillfleisch“.
Spurensuche in Istanbul: In der türkischen
Metropole wird der Döner meist so serviert.
Hier ist Döner Kebab, anders als in
Deutschland, kein günstiger Imbiss.
Der norwegische Foodblogger
Vidar Bergum lebt seit 2015 hier
und befasst sich schon länger mit der
Geschichte des traditionellen Dönertellers.
Döner Kebab war klassischerweise
ein Gericht, das man im Sitzen isst.
So, wie es gerade vor mir steht,
auf Reis mit etwas gegrilltem Gemüse.
Der Döner Kebab hat seinen Ursprung
vor einigen Jahrhunderten
als gegrilltes Fleisch am Spieß und tauchte
an verschiedenen Orten in der Türkei auf.
In der Türkei ist das Fleisch der
Hauptdarsteller beim Döner.
Weder Soße noch Salat sollen seinen
Geschmack verfälschen.
Grillmeister İdris Başak betrachtet die
deutsche Art der Zubereitung skeptisch.
Rotkohl? Für uns ist das seltsam.
Rotes Fleisch passt nicht zu Rotkohl.
Kartoffeln, Tomaten, Zwiebeln und Paprika
passen viel besser
zu einem Döner Kebab im Brot.
Wir haben noch nie Rotkohl verwendet.
Das hochwertige Fleisch vom Kalb und Lamm
wird aber auch in der Türkei
nicht nur auf dem Teller serviert.
Döner Kebab gibt es auch hier
als Fast Food zum Mitnehmen –
allerdings nicht genauso wie in Deutschland.
Irgendjemand hat die Art von Döner erfunden,
die so allgegenwärtig
in der westlichen Welt geworden ist,
und zwar in Brot gefüllt, mit vielen
verschiedenen Salaten und Soßen.
Das wurde in Deutschland erfunden.
Womöglich von Nevzat Salim:
Er servierte den vielleicht
ersten Döner Deutschlands 1969
bei einem Straßenfest
in der süddeutschen Stadt Reutlingen.
Der Stand war hier.
Ich weiß ... ich erinnere mich auch, da sind
auch viele Leute ...sind gestanden hier.
Hier haben wir auch geschnitten, ja?
Ich bin sicher, dass ich der Erste bin, der
Döner nach Deutschland gebracht hat.
Wenn ich das gewusst hätte,
hätte ich auch damals vor 50 Jahren den
Döner patentiert [patentieren lassen].
Sie haben uns gefragt: Ja, was ist das?
Sie haben gedacht,
wir schneiden Leberkäse oder so, gell?
Ich bin sehr stolz,
dass ich ein Stück auch dabei bin,
bei dieser Dönergeschichte!
So hat er damals den Dönerspieß
geschichtet, aus Rind- und Lammfleisch.
Das Fleisch schneidet er
immer mit dem Messer.
Fladenbrot gab es damals nicht in Reutlingen,
daher füllte er einfach schwäbische Brötchen
mit Joghurt,
Fleisch,
Petersilien-Zwiebeln, Tomate –
fertig war der wohl erste Döner Deutschlands!
Doch auch Berlin gilt als Geburtsort.
Der bereits verstorbene Kadir Nurman soll in
einer Imbissbude am Bahnhof Zoo
Anfang der 70er-Jahre den Döner deutscher
Art erfunden haben.
Mehr als 1000 Dönerbuden
gibt es heute in der deutschen Hauptstadt,
von einfach bis edel.
Im Zentrum Berlins entwickelt Deniz Buchholz
immer neue Döner-Varianten –
zum Beispiel mit Mango und anderen
ungewöhnlichen Zutaten.
Ich glaub eher,
es ist ein deutsch-türkisches Gericht.
Es ist auch ein Zeichen
der multikulturellen Freundschaft.
Also, wir fangen halt beim anatolischen
İskender-Kebab an,
bis hin zum gentrifizierten Berlin-Mitte-Döner
mit Trüffel und Spargel dazu –
bisschen fancy, bisschen versaut, aber
trotzdem halt auch was Gutes für die Seele!
Döner Kebab – eine türkisch-deutsche
Erfolgsgeschichte!